when you were speaking about your
younger brother I could even understand
that yeah he's your younger brother yes
you should protect him because he's more
vulnerable than you are but when you
start bringing in the part of even if
it's my older brother I think that is
coming from a very masculine standpoint
and you might think it's not but that's
the reality you might think it's not
gender based for you to protect others
but it actually is it's a masculine
trait and the reason the reason the
reason why you feel the reason why you
feel like you should do that is exactly
because of what you said because you gr
you grew up around so many boys so
you've picked up a lot of masculine
without even realizing it